a group of survivors who live in a
post-apocalyptic world are unaware that
a woman among them has a messiah himself
inside so today in cinema recap i'll
show you legion a netflix movie the film
begins with michael's landing on earth
where we can see that he has a pair of
huge wings since he is one of the angels
in this story who has fallen to earth he
furiously cuts his wings with a knife
losing his angel powers he enters a
house to heal his wounds and takes some
weapons with him to equip himself with
meanwhile in the city there's a lot of
disaster police everywhere michael
leaves a house with weapons in hand the
police threaten him but he easily gets
rid of one of them at that moment we see
how one of the policemen quickly turns
into an angel and asks michael what he
is doing since he must be on a different
mission but the angel sees that michael
has rebelled against god's orders so he
tells him that he and the child he wants
to protect are going to die together
then we meet jeep and charlie she is
pregnant but does not want to continue
her pregnancy and jeep vainly tries to
convince her otherwise even though he is
not the father in another scene we meet
bob the owner of a restaurant who is
trying to repair a tv there are more
people who will be important to this
story like howard sandra and their
daughter audrey we also meet kyle who
was just looking for gasoline and
arrives at the restaurant
charlie works there and she's smoking
outside despite the fact that she is
pregnant
kyle warns her that it is not good for
the baby although she ignores him
jeep sees them chatting and worries that
the traveler is bothering her then
charlie and kyle enter the restaurant
and we can see that charlie and her boss
don't get along even though it's jeep's
father one of the customers gets upset
with bob since jeep does not have his
car ready quickly so bob scolds him and
they have a little argument as bob tells
him that charlie and her baby are not
this responsibility they relax and after
bob gives his son some advice he goes
back to his business jeep stayed outside
and he can see that something is wrong
because there is a strange cloud of dust
in the sky inside the restaurant bob
turns on the television and everyone
watches a weird emergency image but they
don't know what it is about meanwhile
kyle talks to his ex-wife on the phone
but loses communication they start to
worry about what happened then another
client arrives at the restaurant which
is an old woman charlie takes her order
while the lady calls her by her name and
also greets the other clients they ask
the old woman about the emergency on the
tv but she only says not to worry about
it because it will end soon then she
asks charlie when her baby will be due
and they talk normally until the lady
suddenly says that the baby will go to
hell the old woman does strange things
and insult others howard gets up to
argue with her for the bad comments she
said but once she's close enough she
bites his neck and tells everyone that
they're going to die one man named percy
throws a frying pan at the woman but she
doesn't get hurt then she jumps between
the walls and begins to chase everyone
and then she looks at jeep and tells him
that he will not be able to protect
charlie jeep has a gun but it's
difficult for him to shoot the old woman
first he yells at him to do it and a
shot is heard but it came from kyle who
killed the old woman
they try to help howard who is still
bleeding on the ground kyle offers his
help to take howard to the hospital so
they get in the car they all get scared
by the cloud that look like dust in the
sky so they decide to go back jeep and
bob are scared by what happened and jeep
regrets not having had the courage to
shoot
because if it hadn't been for kyle more
people could have been injured they
noticed that the old woman had sharp
teeth and a very suspicious appearance
so everyone wonders where she came from
kyle and the others return they also see
a police car approaching which is driven
by michael
bob threatens him with the gun and asked
to show his teeth to verify that there
are not pointed like the old woman's
once he makes sure of that bob
apologizes and explains to him what had
happened with the old woman michael
tells them he can't believe that they
don't know anything about what's going
on so they ask for explanations michael
easily disarms bob and the situation
becomes tense
first he tries to calm him down and
michael tells everyone that the
creatures are almost there so he returns
the gun and takes more out of the car
and gives them to everyone so they can
be ready for when the angels arrive they
all return to the restaurant and cover
all the entrances
the lights go out and bob and some
others go to the roof at that moment a
suspicious ice cream truck arrives so
they prepare for whatever is going to
come a tall thin man comes out sniffing
the air so he can smell and locate them
he yells furiously his limbs grow and he
runs towards them the humans shoot him
until he's dead
along the way more cars arrive with
people who are also controlled by angels
the shots began to stop all the
creatures that arrived but these are too
many and we can even see that there are
even little girls some of the angels
enter the restaurant and take howard
away and when charlie tries to save him
a creature takes her hand because she's
the one they're after charlie manages to
escape but they take howard away kyle
notices that the angels are retreating
and once they're calmed michael begins
to explain to them that they're facing
some kind of apocalypse and that those
who are outside are possessed by angels
percy tells him that they cannot be
angels since angels are good but michael
replies that not everything is what it
seems
jeep questions him why he knows so much
michael replies that he was one of them
before but everyone refuses to believe
him michael tells him that god is angry
with humanity and that he is there to
protect charlie and her baby who is the
last hope for humanity since he is a
messiah charlie does not believe it but
michael says it very seriously that if
the baby dies before being born
everything will be lost michael tells
him that the angels out there want the
baby dead so they should get ready
because the angels will come with more
force percy and kyle keep watching the
ceiling kyle seemed like a bad man after
killing the old woman but he confesses
to percy that he had never shot a gun
before so they both get sentimental
sandra is still worried about her
husband since he was taken by the
possessed people so bob gives her a beer
and tries to calm her down
meanwhile michael talks to jeep and
tells him that he was given a mission
but that he did not agree with it
because he has faith in humanity
michael also tells him that he saw how
humanity became something that neither
he or godlike since humans killed each
other and had created a lot of chaos but
even so he believes that there are good
people out there and he also tells jeep
that he is one of those people since he
wants to protect charlie and his baby at
all costs even though it's not his son
michael had some memory still from when
he had his wings and we can see that he
had a little argument with one of his
brothers an angel named gabriel who is
willing to execute his father's plan to
end humanity michael lets him know that
god still loves humanity they only need
angels to guide them gabriel replied
that it is their duty to obey and if
their father wants all humans dead that
they should make it happen although
michael replied that humanity deserved a
second chance back to the present sandra
gets up and wants to go out to look for
howard as she hears him asking for help
outside when she looks out the window
she can see that he is hanging on an
inverted cross and is also full of huge
blisters the others tell her not to go
outside because it's dangerous but she
ignores them and when she gets close to
her husband he explodes percy manages to
cover her and take her back to the
restaurant but he gets injured and
collapses as the explosion spewed acid
which reached his bones
ball blames himself for what had
happened since he had fallen asleep
while everything took place sandra is
devastated and they tie her up so that
she does not put herself or others at
risk the woman blamed her daughter as
they were moving because of her on the
radio he can hear a man who says that
there's a safe place nearby but michael
warns them that it's better to stay in
the restaurant then we see charlie
putting down her cigarette because she's
now concerned about her baby
and talks to jeep about it she confesses
that she had gone to a clinic to
interrupt her pregnancy but when she was
about to do so she regretted her
decision jeep tells her that he believes
in her and that she will be able to move
on but charlie isn't quite convinced yet
audrey talks with kyle and we see that
she is very sad about her father and her
mother blaming her over everything
meanwhile a father and son arrive in
their truck to load gasoline but they
are reached by angels who run over the
father and take out the child from the
vehicle kyle comes to the rescue bob
sees him and begins to remove the boards
from the door to go out and help them
but michael threatens him with a weapon
so that he doesn't do it since he will
endanger the others kyle takes the boy
and everyone else stands still because
the boy is an angel and bites kyle on
the neck
audrey comes to his rescue and charlie
wants to do the same but michael decides
to go instead michael kills most of the
enemies while the angel boy takes the
opportunity to enter with a knife in his
hand and he tells charlie not to fear
since he only wants to play with her
baby but then he attacks her he cuts her
a couple of times but she covers herself
with the tray and the angel boy cuts his
fingers while trying to stab her charlie
is shocked for a moment but then reacts
and kicks him away michael approaches to
protect charlie but the angel boy
manages to escape
the lights go out and everyone tries to
find the boy in the dark following his
blood trail
michael can find the footprints on the
roof and the boy grabs bob from behind
but michael and jeep help him charlie is
very upset by everything that happened
and comments that the baby is coming
and while they are helping charlie with
labor a kind of war is heard which
scares everyone michael tells him that
the worst angel is coming so they have
to hurry the baby is born and begins to
cry everyone is happy except for the new
mother
audrey carries the baby while we see
that sandra is trying to untie herself
from the ropes michael says that there
will be hope now that the baby is born
but charlie still doesn't even want to
see the baby michael tells him that it
is time to leave since someone else like
him will come to finish the mission that
he did not carry out so jeep realizes
that the mission that michael did not
want to do is kill the baby and the
situation gets tense seeing that the
baby is in great danger charlie
reconsiders and decides to take her son
but at that moment sandra manages to
untie herself and takes the baby because
she thought that if she gives him to the
possessed people they may decide to
leave them alone however shortly after
she goes through a door michael shoots
her and lets go of the baby but she
reacts quickly and manages to rescue him
from the fall at that moment the angel
gabriel michael's brother arrives facing
jeep and trying to kill him with one of
his weapons but jeep manages to evade
him bob supports him with some shots but
gabriel uses his wings as shields to
cover himself from the bullets and while
doing so
he approaches bob with one of his wings
and cuts his stomach then he slaps him
and sends him away meanwhile michael
convinces jeep to leave and take the
others with him
saying that he will go fight gabriel
while they run
he tells him to find the prophets and to
follow the instructions jeep does not
fully understand but he knows that the
health of the baby comes first so they
leave immediately
when they leave through the back door we
can see that the possessed people no
longer attack them now since the baby
has been born
meanwhile michael and his brother argue
the decisions they have made
michael tries to make gabriel see that
what he does has a good purpose but he
believes otherwise and the saving fight
begins michael defends himself with guns
and his hands while gabriel has the
advantage with his wings and the
strength of an angel between struggles
michael manages to grab his enemy by the
neck but gabriel makes a move in which
both of them end up impaled but at the
end only gabriel survives thanks to his
angel powers we see that despite
everything the death of his brother
hurts gabriel and he sheds tears on the
other hand after michael's death a
tattoo appears on jeep's arm which are
the instructions he has to follow april
thought that he had won the fight but
then he hears a noise which comes from
bob who had not died but opened a gas in
the kitchen and created an explosion
that reached gabriel and the angels
outside meanwhile the other boys are on
their way to protect the baby but at
that moment something falls on top of
the car it's gabriel who managed to
survive the explosion they managed to
throw him out of the car but the angel
takes audrey with him and then the
vehicle goes off-road jeep and charlie
with the baby try to get away from the
place but gabriel appears again and hits
jeep
the angel chases charlie but jeep does
not give up and jumps on the angel
without fear although gabriel easily
knocks him down gabriel is determined to
finish jeep off but at that moment
michael comes to his rescue gabriel
cannot believe that michael is alive and
michael tells him that while he wanted
to give his father what he wanted
michael gave him what he needed they
fight again and michael wins quickly
although he spares gabriel's life and
lets him go michael says goodbye to jeep
and tells him that the real savior is
the one who takes care of the baby jeep
and charlie are ready to do that job and
create a better world
the end if you like this video please
leave a like and subscribe to continue
receiving the recaps of the best action
movies my name is tc and i'll see you in
the next video goodbye